canada what a decent beautiful country
filled with nice people unfortunately
it's now an authoritarian country justin
trudeau's government has just outlawed
independent journalism in canada
government now requires a journalist
possess a journalism license now to get
that license the journalists have to
report favorably on justin trudeau's
government rebel news is one of canada's
few honest news outlets did not get a
license
right that's called censorship and it's
not surprising last year justin trudeau
tried to have rebel news banned from
covering a debate in canada a judge
overturned that ban and allowed a rebel
news reporter inside the debate hall
here's how justin trudeau responded to
that ruling
the reality is
organizations
organizations like yours
that continue to spread misinformation
and disinformation
on the science around vaccines around
how we're going to actually get through
this pandemic and be there for each
other and keep our kids safe
is part of why we're seeing such
unfortunate
anger and
lack of
understanding of basic science and quite
frankly you're
i won't call it a media organization
so you criticize me therefore you
shouldn't be able to talk that guy's a
fascist just to be totally clear ezra
levant is not he founded rebel news he
joins us tonight ezra thanks so much for
coming on this one of those stories it's
just hard to believe
reading it as a longtime fan of your
country that this could be allowed to
happen have we overstated it
well it's not yet illegal to do
journalism without that
license it's a government license called
the qualified canadian journalism
organization license a government panel
reviews you they spent one year
reviewing rebel news looking through
more than a hundred of our stories a
panel of five people in secret we don't
even know what they said or did or what
they looked at and they claimed that
only one percent of our stories are news
so we don't get the license now we're
not outlawed but there's all sorts of
sticks and carrots that come with it for
example just last week trudeau announced
that he is going to compel
facebook and google to down rank
non-licensed journalists like us and
boost his trusted friendly journalists
so we're going to be hidden and he's
going to compel the internet giants to
punish us he's also changing the income
tax act to punish us if you have a
government license your subscribers can
write off their subscription at tax time
if you're an independent journalist like
us no dice
of course there are hundreds of millions
of dollars that he is hosing with a fire
hose at his trusted licensed journalists
and he's now compelling google and
facebook to fund journalists too so now
you've got literally 99 of canadian
media companies that are dependent on
justin trudeau and soon google and
facebook for a huge chunk of their
revenues there's no way those
journalists can be free and independent
we're not banned yet although we are
banned from government events as you uh
said earlier but i'm worried that he's
done all this in two years the worst is
yet to come he may well ban us yet
well if he's forcing the tech monopolies
to downgrade your content i mean it's a
distinction without a difference your
effect you're you're banned from
reaching readers so my question is what
about the rest of canadian media they're
going along with this has anyone at the
cbc canadian broadcasting corporation
stood up to defend you
any of your newspapers to defend you
1500 canadian news media companies are
on the tape now they don't all have
these journalism licenses yet but
they're all taking money from trudeau
he made a special 61 million dollar
payment to them right before the
election none of them reported that 1500
news media companies cut up a 61 million
dollar gift
none of them reported that so the thing
is since they're in on it they can't
very well report it and they certainly
can't very well object to it it used to
be that the liberals of canada were for
civil rights and free speech and
separation of you know government and
the media those days are done
you can really count on one hand's
fingers the independent media left in
the country and trudeau hates them we
were the ones who covered the trucker
rebellion as you know and and trudeau
hated the truckers because they were the
one group that opposed him he hates us
for the same reason he sees the bank
accounts of truckers without legal
process i'm worried that if he's gone
this far in two years by the time he
finishes his term three years from now
i'm worried that he's going to start to
treat us like the truckers
i don't know will he seize our bank
accounts will he
ask google and facebook to de-list us
all together i know that sounds paranoid
but so far he's done everything he
threatened he would do
it's china and he they're so fragile
you're one little news organization and
they can't stand any scrutiny it really
tells you a lot ezra thank you so much
for coming on saying godspeed we are
rooting for you for sure
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight